this stand-up special is fantastic thank
you were getting you are getting so much
love yeah from first of all fans love it
celebrities celebrities now you've got
big celebrities who are who are who are
saying hey this is a fantastic space a
lot of people from Diddy diddy Steve
Harvey Jamie Foxx Martin Lawrence
everybody to change to change has never
given it up for me for reasons I don't
understand people are lining up and
saying we just just love it
yeah man deal you let's just be
everybody be showing so much support man
I want to thank everyone who has watched
it or who has told anybody else and if
you haven't watched it please go see the
streaming on Netflix I do me that favor
yeah yeah yeah it's really you know
you've some really good advice yeah
you have really good advice you advise
you advise old people you think old
people should stay in their Lane yeah
they should just stop trying to do new
dances that these kids are doing really
alone stay in your lane you can't be in
the club over 40 like yes you can and
I'll tell you how you got to stay in
your lane like this is you right now
this is the only dance that you can do
over 40 that's all you can do yeah no I
want to try I want to get out there and
I want to show what I could no no no
even with your string dance that you do
yeah the older you get you got to bring
that string in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Wow just with your thumbs right there
you also you really you you've said and
you believe this passionately and you
talked about it that you think white
people need to get in touch with God you
do you all do you got to get God praise
man you got to give a praise you know no
matter what it is you gotta give it give
God some love you know how do you do
that your everyday life like little
stuff you just gotta acknowledge what
God do like if you ordered a chicken
sandwich you tell them no cheese but
they end up putting cheese on there
anyway that's God telling you you need
to eat that cheese you acknowledge that
you gotta say won't he do it and then to
yourself you gotta say yes he will
really yeah do it yes he will yep out
there for you won't he do it yes he will
if you go to a bar and you drink for 16
hours right right we usually do this
like $700 right but they'd leave off a
couple zeros and your tab is not $7
right that's God telling you that hey I
got two free drink free drinks for you
right and you got to save yourself won't
he do it there you go
yes you will yes you is you get it wrong
though you don't go yes yeah
my guess is its yes he wins he will
that's how you got to do it any drinking
for six they threw me out of you all you
are you know how many people wanted
tickets here tonight and you got the
tickets won't he do it
Wow they are not half of them were like
well this wasn't our first choice wheel
of fortune you this is actually kind of
a compliment but people are using jokes
from your special your special so much
good stuff in it that people are using
some of your bits
yeah even businesses like I do this bit
which is a legitimate question I asked
to do bigger women get kidnapped right
that's a legitimate but but restaurants
start making signs and stuff going be
safe eat cake right beautiful you found
one this is a real someone yeah you saw
this look that's crazy they took that
from you it took that from me you're not
getting paid I'm not getting nothing
yeah I ain't even gettin okay yeah
you've got another thing you you got a
little catch phrase that you used on the
special that has caught on with people
yes I say slap that's another kid that's
the catchphrase well a lot of people
been saying slap is sound like a plan
that's what it is sounds like a plan
yeah you do a really funny thing about
using your cousin my cousin yeah yeah
he's gay you know he bet come on let's
go over here let's go to the party we
should get here free because I know the
bounce and I'm like okay he be like slap
not be like
so who's using it you've got like people
from some mother my son's mother she was
saying it first though try saying it
first you should always stay slap and I
was gonna put a name in my special but
she is I keep my goddamn name out your
mouth and I don't so what's going well
but then wait isn't it like ESPN or
someone ESPN use this yeah yeah I seen
it alright it was like lying dry ball
should he go to second base
laugh sound like a plan I was like oh